welcome back uh where i had just left
off we were trying to figure out this
this this area between these two curves
and we figured out that it's really the
area between the curves between the
points
0 x equals 0 and x equals 1. and i was
proposing a way to do it let's figure
out the entire area under the square
root of x from
from
from 0 to 1 and we can subtract from
that this purple area which is the area
under x squared so just based on the
last example we did we could just write
the indefinite integral and i'm not
going to rewrite the fundamental theorem
from calculus because i think you yeah
you know that by now
let me do it in a loud color
magenta
so i want to know the the larger area
right the area under just the square
root of x that's kind of like the
combined area
well that's just
from zero to one
the integral of square root of x right
because square root of x is the green
function
dx
and i want to subtract from that
the area
from 0 to 1
what's under x squared
x squared
dx
i just want to make a point this could
have just been rewritten this way you
could just rewrite a new function which
is the difference of these two functions
and it would have been equivalent you
could have said this this isn't kind of
a step of the problem but you could have
done it this way in fact some people
start this way
say this is the same thing as the
integral from 0 to 1
of square root of x
minus x squared
dx
so you could do it as two separate
problems uh two separate indefinite
integrals we could do it as uh one in
definite integral actually that might be
even simpler because when you evaluate
it from one to zero it simplifies things
a little bit so let's stick with the
second one so first of all we just have
to figure out what the antiderivative of
this inner expression is
so you haven't seen square root of x yet
do you think you know how to do it well
i think you do
let's say that equals
square root of x is just x to the
one-half power right
so we just use the same anti-derivative
rules we've always used we raise it one
more power so it becomes
x
to the three-halves right it was one
half we added one to it and then we
divide by this new exponent so dividing
by a fraction is like multiplying by its
reciprocal right
so it's two thirds
x to the three halves
and then
minus i think the second term is pretty
easy for you minus one third
x to the third right that's the
antiderivative of minus x squared minus
one third x to the third
and we're going to have to evaluate this
thing
at
0 and 1 and subtract the difference
subtract the this function this
expression evaluated at 0 from this
expression valued at 1.
well this equals i'm i think i'm running
out of space what what happens when x
equals 1 1 to the 3 halves is 1 1 to the
third is 1 so it's 2 3 minus 1 3 well
that's easy it's 1 3
right i just put 1 in for x and then
when x is equal to zero what is this
expression equal that's easy too that's
zero
so there you go one third minus zero or
one third
that's that's kind of neat that that the
area between um you know i i find this
kind of exciting because you would
if if i just my intuition i was like oh
i have these two curves and i mean you
know they do intersect at a nice
integral number a nice integer number
but you know what it's probably going to
be some really messy number of
you know what the area is between these
two curves right maybe who knows maybe
it'll involve some you know a circle
involves pi which is this really messy
number so maybe all curves have these
kind of messy areas but
this one it's you know just one of those
neat things about matt the area between
the square root of x and x squared is is
one third which is a which is a pretty
clean number
i think i'm gonna
let it actually let me do one more
problem since i have time
it's a bit of a trick problem i mean
it's not that you might actually find
this easy
but
let's figure out the area between
f of x
is equal to
um
is equal to well just let me just i
don't know
x to the fifth i'm going to do something
simple let me draw it
actually
what's going on okay look at that
okay let me draw the x axis
okay
and i'll draw x
well x to the fifth is going to go up
super fast gonna go like that something
like that it's gonna go real fast let's
say i wanted to figure out the areas
come on this side can go real fast too
between that instead of figuring out the
area between the x-axis and that
and f x i want to figure out the area
between
f of x
and
um
instead of figuring out this bottom area
right like the normal problems we've
done we would figure out this this this
type of area you know between two points
let's say i want to figure out
the area
inside of the the curve
where
the height here
is 32
so i want to figure out this area this
area inside the curve
how do we do that
well
one way we could do it is just like we
did the last one we can figure out some
function that's essentially a line a
horizontal line that goes straight
across here
and we'll essentially just be
figuring out the area between the two
functions so what's a function that's a
line that just goes straight at y equals
32 i think i just gave you the answer
exactly let's make let me stick it to
that let me stick with that
greenish color
so we could say g of x
is equal to 32. it's just a constant
function it just goes straight straight
across
and then we need to figure out what the
area is between the two so we need to
figure out what are these two points
right
so when does x to the fifth equal 32
that's that's i mean you could solve it
algebraically but i think you you know
you could say x to the fifth equals 32
x
is equal to
two
and actually you know what i made a
mistake
let's say that this is not equal to x to
the fifth let's say that f of x is equal
to
x to the absolute value of
x to the fifth because the mistake
obviously x to the fifth is not a
parabola looking thing x to the fifth
goes negative like this but i have
committed so much to this cup shape that
i'll i'll make it the absolute value of
x to the fifth so if i say the x
absolute value of x to the fifth is
equal to 32 i think you see where i
realize my mistake but if i say the
absolute value of x to the fifth is
equal to 32 there's two places where
that's true it's x is equal to plus or
minus two right these are the two points
i should have done something with an
even exponent so i could have had this
cup shape but anyway the absolute value
solved my problem so what is this area
so we know it's between negative 2 and 2
so we just set up the indefinite
integral it's the indefinite integral
from -2
to 2
of the top function the top boundary 32
minus the bottom boundary
minus
well this will this will be a little bit
tricky but minus the absolute value of x
to the fifth
dx
and actually instead of doing this i
think you can see that there's symmetry
here so we could just figure out this
area and multiply by two right this
problem's a little hairy this problem
ended up being just because i had a bad
choice of initial function
not exactly what i wanted but we'll
we'll we'll work on forward so instead
of doing that let's do the integral from
to 2 of 32
minus x to the fifth
dx
and then multiply that by 2.
so what is that that's 32
x
minus x to the
sixth over six
and we're going to evaluate it from two
and zero at two it's sixty-four
minus sixty-four over six
right two to the sixth is sixty-four
and then
at 0
32 times 0 is 0 and then x to the 6th
that's 0. so the answer is 64 minus 64
over 6.
i'm about to run out of time that's just
a fraction problem there oh and that's
that's half of it right so we want to
multiply that by 2. so if we multiply
that by 2
we get what 128
minus 128 over 6. i haven't figured out
what it is well i guess we could figure
out it's 128 times 1 minus
1 6
or 128 times 5 6
and i don't know what that is we can
i can multiply if i wanted to but i have
10 seconds left so i'll leave you there
hope i didn't confuse you see you soon